[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 este mes de
noviembre la leyenda de la salsa juve
arroz yo cumpliría 67 años y por eso se
estrenó la película rebelión que logrará
adentrarnos en las emociones del
cantante y músico colombiano su director
José Luis arrugelas nos ofrece un viaje
un poco claustrofóbico pero con una
inteligente construcción por los cuartos
de hotel que acogieron al salsero
durante sus momentos de creación musical
de sueños delirios y fantasmas una
coproducción colombiana Argentina y
estadounidense que rinde homenaje al
artista de Cartagena y a la legado que
dejó al mundo con sus canciones
la música de nosotros es una lucha por
la paz por eso es que para los políticos
están peligrosos otra película que
queremos destacar este mes es la secuela
del éxito de Marvel black panther
Walking Dead forever una superproducción
que se diferencia de las otras por su
gran estética afro su banda sonora en
una fuerte carga emocional porque su
actor principal
falleció en 2020 la nueva película Borra
las líneas entre un duelo en la vida
real y otro en la ficción y se podría
reprochar a la cinta sus buenas
intenciones pero el elenco y el balance
entre acción humor y reflexión terminan
convenciéndonos veamos el trailer
[Aplausos]
[Música]
vamos a hablar ahora de literatura y más
exactamente de mangas estos cómics
típicamente japoneses un mundo muy
cerrado en el que un francés ha
conseguido hacerse un hueco se llama ONU
y es uno de los pocos mangas franceses
nuestro colega de la cadena hermana en
francés se reunió con él en París
frente mío
vengo de un entorno en el que no nos
inclinamos por el arte
[Música]
una librería antes de que me publicaran
en el mundo del manga no es fácil
hacerse un nombre cuando no se viene del
país del sol naciente sin embargo
renolem es un francés que se enamoró del
dibujo desde muy joven en 2006 su primer
manga dreamland ya fue considerada una
Obra maestra
[Música]
la particularidad de terror son los ojos
cerrados y la sonrisa el hecho de que
esté sonriendo hace que realmente quiera
seguir a este pequeño
Este joven es un tímido estudiante de
secundaria de día pero por la noche
viaja al mundo de los sueños para salvar
a las almas de la gente con su mágico
poder de fuego
[Música]
15 años después
700.000 ejemplares vendidos y aún así el
autor decidió remasterizar los primeros
volúmenes de la saga
hagamos así empecé a leer mi serie vi
las cualidades y lo que les podía gustar
a los lectores que venían a verme en la
firma algo que me costaba entender la
locura en torno al Dreams pero también
vi todos los defectos de los primeros
volúmenes y eso estaba realmente en mí
era orgánico me picaba los ojos me dolía
en realidad después también progresé en
el ritmo el diálogo es lo esencial
la fiebre del manga ha hecho en Francia
no deja de hacer feliz a las librerías
pero no hay que presumir según renolet
los llaman toque Francés pero no estoy
de acuerdo conociendo a bastantes
autores todos tenemos una sensibilidad
una voluntad de contar una historia
diferente Así que si tuviéramos quedar
un nombre a esta ola diría el toque no
japonés tenemos esa pretensión de ser
franceses y querer poner nuestra
historia en Francia a toda Costa porque
no muchos lo hacen pero tampoco Hacemos
como Los japoneses
aficionado a Japón pero sin complejo de
inferioridad renal teje las redes de su
imaginación con sus trazos de Lápiz los
fans del manga también podrán descubrir
Las aventuras de The gons en una serie
de animación muy pronto
éramos Este programa con nuestra sección
dedicada a la música empezando con el
estreno de abrirse del portobello la
colaboración en Gallego entre la
cantautora rosalén y el Trío femenino
tan chungueras con letras que lloran a
la gente que deja la vida en el mar y
armonías poderosas rozalén Busca Mostrar
su respeto y agradecimiento por el
folclor de Galicia
[Música]
del lado del rappel from Google jeans
volvió a sus primeros amores con un
instrumental contundente y una
acumulación de referencias y símbolos en
el tema de mi stock el nombre de un
estratega y jefe de guerra ateniense
[Música]
y el dúo de música electrodos de Blaze
nos ofrece dreamer acompañado de un
videoclip grabado en la capital de
senegal Dakar que ellos mismos
dirigieron
[Música]
Nos despedimos con las tablas de surf el
olor a playa y los años 70 del nuevo
sencillo de los estadounidenses hale
steinfield y understand pack la canción
se llama Coast Gracias a ustedes por su
confianza y sigan con nosotros hay más
cultura en francés 24 y France 24.com
[Música]
[Aplausos]